bon service et michel fize merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir sur
rtl france en tant que sociologue
justement comment est-ce que vous
analysez cette mobilisation qui a été
plutôt forte aujourd'hui de la part des
français contre les volumes les
violences policières et l'article 24
précisément de la loi sécurité globale
d'abord je constaterai que cet exécutif
a décidément un problème avec les mots
quand on repense à la distinction entre
activités essentielles ou non essentiels
entre séparatisme ou islamisme et la
sécurité globale
très honnêtement je me suis d'abord
penché sur qu'elle pouvait bien caché
cette expression alors je crois que
cette loi c'est une loi sur la sécurité
de la police et des policiers entendus
globalement comme la réunion de la
police nationale de la police municipale
et des agents privés de sécurité
voilà c'est ça donc c'est la sécurité de
la police qui est en vue dans cette loi
alors il est évident que même dans des
gouvernements très dur je repense
notamment en février 1981 quand on avait
créé la loi sécurité et liberté qui
était une loi vise et visant aussi
assurer la protection des citoyens
eh bien on avait bien compris que on ne
peut pas dissocier sécurité et liberté
voilà et dans cette affaire par rapport
à un article 24 dont tout le monde a
souligné qu'elle était pour le moins
fort mal rédigé eh bien il ya une
suspicion d'atteinte potentiels aux
libertés par une interprétation
extensive qui peut être fait sur le
terrain on peut tout à fait imaginer que
pour éviter qu'un problème de diffusion
d'image encore une fois agressive ne se
pose est bien on interdise à un certain
nombre de journalistes de filmer voir
qu'on détruise le matériel c'est donc je
pense une
loi potentiellement dangereuse et je
crois que les citoyens en se mobilisant
fortement aujourd'hui ont bien montré
qu' il n'était pas dupe
effectivement des attaques potentielles
aux libertés qui était encore une fois
derrière ce texte
cet épisode je dis évidemment
d'interpellations musclées on l'a vu sur
cette vidéo de de michel est clair
est-ce que ce n'a pas que sale cela n'a
pas contribué à ce qui est beaucoup plus
de personnes mobilisées aujourd'hui dans
les rues de france
je m'étonne qu'on s'étonne de telles
images de violence de la part de
policiers
vous savez il suffit de tendre un peu
l'oreille des événements de ce type à
peine moins graves se produisent tous
les jours dans la rue dans des salles de
garde à vue ce matin dans la presse
écrite
il y avait un témoignage d'un d'un
policier de la bac 1 qui disait qu
effectivement il faut arrêter de dire
que on serait face à une minorité de
policiers et qu'il y aurait une
institution qui globalement se porterait
bien
alors minorité ou majorité de policiers
violents et racistes
honnêtement on n'en sait rien il n'y a
pas d'études scientifiques
donc moi je suis assez scandalisé quand
j'entends dire que il ne s'agit que
effectivement de quelques individus
qu'on appelle rapidement brebis drobie
galeuses bon savez entre minorités et
majorité en inventant droit
constitutionnel majorité qualifiée moi
je pense qu'aujourd'hui au bas mot on
est face à une minorité qualifié
importante donc deux policiers qu'ils
peuvent commettre des violences en
fonction de certaines circonstances est
évident que ce que l'on voit là sur les
images
ce sont des circonstances qui peuvent
prédisposer au passage à l'acte et
sortir encore une fois des bornes d'une
violence
effectivement permise par la loi
ce qui permet d'ailleurs de dire qu'il
faut arrêter et d'employer ce langage
sociologique de violence les
tim de l'état n'y a pas de violence n'y
a pas de violence légitime
il ya une violence légale qui est
enfermé dans des textes de loi voilà il
n'y a pas de violence est légitime pour
pour l'état et encore moins de monopole
de la violence de la violence légitime
donc effectivement il ya un problème par
rapport à cette institution je crois
qu'on le dit depuis ce matin il ya un
problème de recrutement
il ya un problème de formation il ya un
problème d'encadrement et d'exemplarité
1 quand on pense que place de la
république les autres jours le policier
qui a fait ce croc en jambe qui lui vaut
aujourd'hui effectivement quelques
désagréments est un commissaire de
police
donc comment effectivement de simples
policiers peuvent agir convenablement si
les hiérarchies pour le coup donne le
mauvais exemple mon de hiérarchie c'est
ce que nous disait effectivement nos
invités spécialistes de la police manque
de formation également des formations
raccourci enfin voilà ils réclament
davantage de moyens
michel fize le gouvernement quelles
responsabilités at-il il tente d'un côté
de protéger les policiers et d'un autre
côté finalement ne contribue pas
tellement à améliorer la confiance
envers les policiers paradoxalement
alors d'abord il faut éviter si on veut
avancer dans ce débat il faut éviter de
mettre en parallèle les violences que
subissent les policiers eux mêmes qui ne
sont pas contestables et les violences
dont ils se rendent coupables parce
qu'encore une fois au néo pas au même
niveau à les policiers sont des agents
d'autorité qui doivent conserver la
maîtrise de soi savez j'ai retrouvé ce
matin les déclarations d'un préfet de
police de paris que monsieur l'allemand
serait je crois bien avisés de relire
voilà ce qu'écrivait ce préfet de police
dans j'irai le nom un peu plus tard il
disait de frapper un manifestant tombé à
terre
c'est se frapper soi-même en
apparaissant sous un jour qui atteint
toute la fonction policière
et de rappeler qu'être policier n'est
pas un métier comme les autres
quand on l'a choisi on en a accepté les
dures exigences
voilà encore une fois il ya un filtre du
recrutement qui n'opère plus voyez-vous
ce qui s'est passé là avec ce problème
de formation c'est aussi ce que j'ai vu
moi même au temps où je travaillais au
sein de l'administration pénitentiaire
c'est le passage de la vocation de
surveillants pénitentiaires à une
situation de motivation alimentaire
pourquoi devient ton policiers pourquoi
devient ton surveillants de prison ben
pour avoir un travail et c'est devenu un
travail comme un autre
donc il faut rappeler que encore une
fois comme le disait donc je donne le
nom de ce préfet de police c'est maurice
grimaud qui en mai 1968 avait d'ailleurs
rédigé une lettre aux policiers
indiquant qu'il fallait faire attention
de ne pas tomber dans l'excès dans l'
usage de la force
voilà une très belle déclaration qui je
crois aurait mérité d'être prononcée par
le préfet l'allemand le préfet
d'allemands aujourd'hui donc c'est une
tâche encore une fois qu'on ne peut pas
comparer à une autre 1
le métier de policier est un métier
d'autorité avec des pouvoirs importants
et pour revenir à cette loi sur la
sécurité globale et on comprend qu'elle
puisse inquiéter
on s'aperçoit que c'est une loi qui
encore une fois augmente
d'abord la coordination entre les
différentes formes de police est ce
qu'il paraît quand même pour le moins
effectivement inquiétant c'est que à
titre expérimental on s'apprête à
élargir les compétences des policiers
municipaux pour les mettre à peu près au
niveau des pouvoirs des policiers
nationaux en leur permettant notamment
le contrôle d'identité
voilà le contrôle d'identité qui est
quand même dans notre droit démocratique
dans notre état de droit
quelque chose qui ne doit pas être
pratiqué sans être entouré d'un certain
nombre de conditions légales qui les
permettent ces contrôles d'identité
michel fize d'avoir répondu ce soir en
direct à nos questions sur rt france